خوفا من ان ينقلب السحر على الساحر يقود
ايلون ماسك حمله تطالب بوقف تطوير برنامج
لانه يشكل خطرا كبيرا على المجتمع دعوه
ماسك هذه جاءت عبر رساله مفتوحه وقع عليها
اكثر من الف شخص دعوا فيها الى التوقف
لمده سته اشهر عن تطوير انظمه اقوى من
روبوت الدردشه
الذي اطلقته شركه اوبن اي اي في الاونه
الاخيره الرساله طرحت عده اسئله ابرزها هل
ينبغي ان نطور عقولا غير بشريه قد تتفوق
علينا عددا وذكاء وتتفوق علينا وتحل محلنا
وهل يجب ان نسمح للالات باغراق قنواتنا
الاعلاميه بالدعايه والكذب وتقول الرساله
الموجهه انه لا يجب تفويض قرارات كهذه
لقاده تكنولوجيا غير منتخبين والتاكد من
ان اثارها ستكون ايجابيه وان مخاطرها
ستكون تحت السيطره